[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh man
[Music]
okay y'all but to do this earth
okay
[Music]
[Applause]
okay all right let's see if I can see
this [ __ ] I'm gonna play this keep
playing this game one more time
[Music]
skeeball
[Music]
okay this is
working too
[Music]
but don't understand us
[Music]
I think I'm on twitch right now why on
twitch
[Music]
hello twitch
yes we are on switch oh [ __ ] know what
do this there we go
okay gotta fix it
[Music]
fix that
[Music]
there we go
yeah preferred god I gonna play this
[ __ ] hard-ass game
love to people watching me on let's call
it
am I on YouTube can YouTube people see
me
[Music]
oh yeah okay
you got to YouTube work in town all
right let's see if we can do this [ __ ] I
know I'm doing nothing I'm about to I'm
just trying to get set up
damn [ __ ] vicious ass chat man you
guys are the worst
can I just can I get my [ __ ] together
ah here we go ah
all right so I started playing this game
and oh there we go it is work yeah okay
finally got you to
[Music]
[Applause]
you true here we go no I got a sign in
you got a sign in his Eric Griffin
what's up guys
yes mash that light y'all
[Music]
okay here we go I don't know if it does
this game progress [ __ ] but this game
was pretty hard pretty hardcore damn not
the gun I need to like fix my cameras on
my TV's on show but you do I go continue
or load game [ __ ] my xbox is too far
away from me I need to pull this [ __ ] a
little bit closer
welcome to Griffin come on good gaming
has anybody played this game yet yeah
you gotta hit that twitch twitch is fun
YouTube's fun you know what I mean it is
what it is yes oh here we go alright so
where we I got to remember how to do
[ __ ] again oh [ __ ]
thus right these [ __ ] dogs come after
you do damn oh my god oh my god okay
let's go in here oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh my
god is dogs in a dude what
oh my god
okay oh my god okay so I guess you gotta
kill the dogs first I mean damn this
dogs and I do with a samurai sword like
[ __ ] hit one god damn this is hard
[ __ ] like oh my god yo everybody
hello hello chats
I hope the YouTube is company good okay
unseen aid half a skill experience II I
don't know what that [ __ ] is man wait I
got a look at my [ __ ] see what I have
okay alright so I got to healing gored
the pellets
I have no ash ceramic shard what does
that [ __ ] do man
you go like this so you just throw it it
that's all it does
way way way way wait wait wait wait
I mean I don't know what the [ __ ] I'm
doing in this game guys
all right so is there a guy over here oh
there's a guy over there but the
question is I should probably kill these
dogs first huh yeah you know what don't
you think I know dude I'm with you 100%
I need an ak-47 like [ __ ] a sword like
what am I doing with this [ __ ] sword
man you know what kill these [ __ ]
dogs give me your little [ __ ] dogs
you better run [ __ ] dog how do you
still get me okay what it's like I have
a sword
[ __ ] dog she's not oh my god
oh so you can avoid the dark okay okay
okay I'm learning from you guys so you
can avoid the dogs okay all right all
right I understand all right so you can
avoid the dogs all right I'd make that
make sense should that make sense
okay wait I mean if I share this [ __ ] I
need to share the [ __ ] with the world
cuz I'm playing in a hot ass game
hard-ass game okay okay so now where's
that guy yet
oh there he is if I could sneak up on
his ass
oh you know what I bet you I could sneak
up on this dude in this [ __ ] weed
bush oh no I can't look he's already
right there there's no way to sneak
around this guy actually there might be
no what I can't already see me come on
wait
oh I press on the wrong [ __ ] love
that [ __ ] all right is is there a
universe rocket sneak down and kill this
guy no I don't think so
wait wait wait wait wait you know what I
think I can actually
all right let's you know oh yeah son
okay wait is there like
okay all right where's it okay yeah you
know what you gonna go real slow we're
gonna take your real slow yeah we gonna
take your real slow
you're gonna take it slow oh okay oh
this is it
this is okay wait wait wait if I hit oh
[ __ ] I bet if I fall down and hit that
stuff I bet you if I go down here look
at dad check me out
I don't know oh [ __ ] there's a guy right
there - Jesus Christ man just discard oh
you're right
Oh lock on me you guys are so [ __ ]
helpful so if I jump okay I get it
okay so all right what I did was right
okay okay okay let's mess around
oh [ __ ] just resurrect right here I
didn't mean to do that
wait oh [ __ ] come on man where is he
there he is
[Music]
[ __ ]
okay this oh my god dude
oh my god oh my god why would I do that
why would I do that
stupid rot okay that's what I'm trying
to do I'm trying to lock on roll
sideways oh my god this game is a
nightmare
do you understand what I'm saying this
game is a freaking nightmare what I'm
dead again
oh nasty I wish I could skip it okay
this madness oh my god I have to start
over again
wait what oh no I don't how do you fast
travel wait how the [ __ ] do you face
trouble - [ __ ] you've already I guess it
doesn't matter huh
yeah I sliced his neck how the [ __ ] did
he survive that I'm totally with you
100% [ __ ] don't make any sense okay so
if I rest okay okay I get it I get it
now I could travel oh I see I see this
is where we want to go okay okay I get
it now
Willy so you go here then you see where
you want to go ah got it
okay so you have to go to the statues to
travel okay that makes sense now wait
there's too many instructions into some
[ __ ] here we go here we go this
is my spot okay can we go do this [ __ ]
again
[Music]
okay okay I'll lock on to him all right
so if I jump right okay here we go
here we go y'all dodge with the Dodge oh
[ __ ] okay
oh my god just do this to horror oh look
how much power he has oh man I wish you
could change the controls all cat get it
so you can like you could come back once
okay I get it I get it
where is he
we're [ __ ] is he hilarious
oh my god this [ __ ] is
give me oh my oh my god this training
would be helpful okay you know what you
but you know what let's do that all
right let's discus let's let's train
with just how do you [ __ ] get to the
training
[Music]
options you know what I'm training I'm
training with a school of life I'm doing
that life training y'all wait what is
this this guy dead oh well I have to at
least get that first hit in I can't I
can't you know what I mean
yeah I got it I got it wait how do I get
up to you the first time
how the [ __ ] did I get up to bow
well there we go okay here we go
I got it I got a do this [ __ ] again
because okay lock onto this [ __ ]
[ __ ] how the [ __ ] is he not yes to tell
me that neck it is oh I see like there's
a power head okay so like if you hold
this down okay
oh [ __ ] I'm [ __ ] resurrecting like a
dumbass tell it okay oh my god well that
was a waste of time
I'll go back up and jump on him again
yeah I guess that could work
okay this [ __ ] is impossible do the
finishing depo can only be performed
once on the enemy's deathblow markers
are gone
some rare very powerful enemies require
disco [ __ ] okay see only could do that a
couple times
that makes sense
oh [ __ ] I did not want to do that y'all
what am i doin
kinda lucky Becca Oh God
Oh check me out with the jump in this
[ __ ] yeah
okay so if I do this okay so that's okay
ah if I hold it down
is that okay got it
okay so if I go clap okay okay
oh my god I don't does he regenerate oh
my god this is impossible
alright here we go let's do this [ __ ]
again I gotta get this death blow in for
sure okay that's okay so lock onto just
some [ __ ] oh my god okay come on
please okay so don't panic Griffin oh
man how do you get back up I use my
[ __ ] claw get back up oh my god
okay can I like jump on his ass again
Oh many cut my [ __ ] legs off okay
I'll shut resurrect just gonna die it's
gonna die
this [ __ ] is impossible man did you see
how impossible this [ __ ] is okay
[Music]
okay here we go
okay okay
hmm
all right
I mean maybe I shouldn't waste my
[ __ ] cuz you only get two of them
what does get this guy's really hard
like this isn't I haven't even really
played the game and I mean this [ __ ] is
taking forever
okay here we go
I'm [ __ ] neck chopping this dude and
it's only taken off like a [ __ ]
sliver of his health damn it only no
sense
you know what I mean all right here we
go
yeah yeah yeah stick and move all right
okay so this is like this is all about
patience come on come on what Winston oh
my god how's he kicking me oh [ __ ] wait
what is that little [ __ ] what does
that mean
that little [ __ ] in a little Japanese
simple that comes up on the screen
that's red does anybody know what that
is
oh okay all right so that's the
unblockable attack when at that Japanese
lettering comes on the screen that means
this [ __ ] about to kill me is
that what that means
oh okay okay
that makes sense okay that makes [ __ ]
sense okay you know what
[Music]
okay so I'm gonna travel how do you
travel to to to train how do you [ __ ]
train anybody know how to train back if
I go back the rest
oh okay okay ah ah to go here okay all
right I got it got it all right we're
gonna do some training let's go do some
training I got past the first part the
other day and this part is I like this
is some hard [ __ ] okay come on why does
it keep saying what you saw the safety
role while down or posture okay oh I'm
already here so how do you train now
where's the [ __ ] training was that in
here with this guy this guy this lady
returned from the dead the power of the
Dragons I never thought I'd forgive me
to assist okay I'm not telling you to
trust me
however okay okay okay okay what seeds
yes medicinal what adding me if you find
any bring them to me all right
give gourd seeds I don't have any I'd
like to make a request
what is it please yeah this dialogue is
just like I can't okay goodbye
all right where the [ __ ] do you train
with this dude I found one shinobi - yes
I said what's he doing - my prosthetic
oh [ __ ]
fitting prosthetic to regular shinobi
tools found in okay alright what is this
[ __ ] load create low load it I don't
know what the [ __ ] what I'm doing
a shirker can wheel prosthetic tool
fitted to the press today it costs
spirit emblem to use pull it load it
into the wheel and launch it at a target
in a single flowing motion this swiftly
thrown sure kid damages enemys vitality
and posture okay alright this is like a
throwing star some [ __ ] huh a shuttle
kid attacked by throwing okay oh wait
wait arty yeah but yeah but how do you I
don't understand that hearty but isn't
arty like oh right right right right
okay I get it I get it okay that makes
sense
okay what's he doing why is it [ __ ]
taking so long
oh okay okay there he's finished I'd
like to do it again
what does he already do it is he still
working on the [ __ ] what's happening
right now okay it's done okay all right
um okay
Oh prosthetic tool opening equipment
menu use prosthetic tool Aarti switch
prosthetic - okay all right
can the scene open the menu all right I
see - [ __ ] that is
Oh got it that makes sense now
yes okay I see okay okay how do you have
that [ __ ] Oh No okay and then you okay
so I have that how the [ __ ] do you use
it though oh it's are you just press RT
got it okay guys
where do you train you know what I mean
like I don't understand where you train
is this training right here guys where
the [ __ ] you tree
up the path what path this path out here
okay oh I take my first right okay not
this [ __ ] right no okay all you go up
here is just where I'm going outside I
was just a training dude oh [ __ ] this
[ __ ] goddamn okay
I killed him but always getting up was
this guy trained it's just how to train
in you okay oh I get it alright just a
training guy okay yeah but he's not
teaching me any moves
Oh got it I see I see train attacks okay
here we go got it guys got it got it got
it okay RB attack after breaking posture
deathblow okay
okay all right all right okay target on
okay okay just a quick hit got it okay
okay okay okay okay so hit them hit them
okay so you got quick be quick beat got
it got it got it got it got it okay oh
[ __ ] I just wasted my thing does it read
does it redo it okay I don't know
okay let's do that again I'm gonna train
okay let's do the deflections okay okay
lb the movement land to fight are be
breaking posture deathblow alright okay
I still don't get it
[ __ ] okay okay oh wait god damn it oh my
god dude something yes something's wrong
damn it oh [ __ ] that second attack is
the one that gets me [ __ ] here we go oh
[ __ ]
lb is enemy attacks to flex see you
kitchen okay oh [ __ ]
okay so when they hit you like that you
lose power okay oh man
okay kid I get it oh [ __ ] I you know
what I know what I'm doing wrong I got
to stop holding our B down [ __ ] man I
don't have anymore that [ __ ]
Oh forward
okay oh my god
okay that is their fourth hit okay so
after four hits you go down that's the
[ __ ] I don't understand right there man
I'm jumping away from this one okay I
gotta jump away not to the side way yes
okay here we go here we go
jump away what okay I can't jump
I gotta used to dodge I just say this
wrong okay there it is there it is we
got a little dodge action going huh
get back in there oh yeah block block
not oh my god you know I got a dodge
away from the story hand that's what it
is yeah that's what it is
okay okay okay oh it's that it's not
fast enough okay no I guess you got to
get a double tap okay just do a quick
dodge deflect oh I can't youtube dodge
deflect that's it right there jump back
jump forward
okay okay
[Music]
see that little dodge move y'all oh
don't hold LB okay got you oh yes chance
we're doing this together okay all right
all right I got it
okay let's train step dodge now in that
case okay step jobs are you to avoid
attacks evade and attack perform death
pose step dodge after dodge RB okay okay
okay here we go
all right here we go
I'll have to lock on to this
[ __ ] okay here we go here we go
step dodge Oh this [ __ ] got me
oh [ __ ] I just you just took me down yes
oh [ __ ] face me again [ __ ] come on come
on yeah come on I dodged oh [ __ ] me this
dodging is hard
what what's wrong man the dodging is
like Oh what move was that okay all
right I'm starting to see all right you
got it
splendidly done okay match me with the
Oh better way to what's wrong why do you
go after depend the other okay cancel
okay well we did it okay now it's time
to go right time is it [ __ ] I got twenty
minutes and I gotta leave yo
okay
all right um we want to travel Oh Willie
do I need to purchase spirit emblems not
another what the [ __ ] is that I guess I
gotta find money okay what is that but
now I'm gonna go hero all right here we
go right okay so you don't hole okay so
if you hold lb down that's how you block
like you keep the sword up but when the
sword is coming you want to tap to pass
how is that right I guess here we go
y'all here we go yeah here we go yeah
[Music]
okay I'm [ __ ] killing this dude right
the [ __ ] now
all right here we go
oh [ __ ] okay okay here we go lock onto
just some [ __ ] here we go here
we go y'all here we go here we go
alright we got it now oh [ __ ] I forgot
you can't block those okay okay
resurrection on this [ __ ]
[Music]
[ __ ] why did I've dodged just so man ok
what is a yellow posture meter I don't
know what the [ __ ] that is
so somebody explain that because I am
lost I don't know what maybe oh I bet
you the elite controller will be great
like right cuz you put like nod yes it
wouldn't matter
just do the [ __ ] again
uh I'm not gonna even get past this guy
but I want to get past this guy here we
go y'all just [ __ ] get his power
back
oh is is YouTube [ __ ] up again oh my
god it's not supposed to be dude I'm not
even using
oh my god dude that is so freaking
annoying it's like I don't know why my
CPU usage is so high right now that
doesn't make any sense
my hideous cuz of this app you know what
let me turn this app off
[Music]
like on twitch there's no problems
YouTube man it just cannot work properly
man
[Music]
I'm gonna just close everything else but
my streaming app
[Music]
you know what that already made a
difference
okay there we go
[Music]
all right
let me see then I can't watch the chat
unless I go to my phone or my laptop
over there just put this right here
okay chat okay chat
okay there we go
turn lying down
[Music]
skip at there we go
okay oh [ __ ] wrong controller
I think twitch is just better suited for
[Music]
gaining like they just their servers are
ready for it YouTube's trying too hard
but it should even matter with the dual
streaming because I'm using restream
like I'm just sending one stream to like
restream i'm not even dual streaming on
my Wirecast
so that's kind of annoying that that
what you call it that is it's doing that
you know whatever I got a better
computer coming so we're all good
I know YouTube is YouTube
all right I can go in between the two
when you go over here to twitch to see
what's going on with the twitch folks
page which folks
[Music]
let's see
all right there we go
yes better off both cuz I closed I
closed an app that what that was so you
just can't be doing anything else on
your computer that's what it is all
right here we go guys I'm gonna get to
some other [ __ ] right now all right
I'll keep man I keep the wrong [ __ ]
thing man whoo [ __ ] see that get out of
that one okay
okay son damn it
oh [ __ ] he was trying to grab me damn it
[ __ ] army pellets take my kneeling or
[ __ ]
check me out oh he's [ __ ] himself
[Music]
okay okay come on baby come on baby
alright alright here we go
No
oh my god oh my god oh my god
sweet we gonna be resurrect [ __ ] right
he's almost dead dead [ __ ] oh
I'm sweating this [ __ ] I need some you
know what I need this I need some gamer
dude where's my gamer dude oh my god
that was that was it right there that
was it son oh my god where the [ __ ] is
my god dammit phone oh my god
my god why are these apps closing okay
there it is there we go here we go oh
okay okay all right so you go pray at
the Statue is that gonna like do some
[ __ ] for me wait what is this over here
oh [ __ ] look at this Oh Fistful of ash
god I could have used that against this
guy
Jesus all right I gotta heal myself
Healing gourd none no pelts no healing
gourd
Jesus so can you heal yourself with the
statue
oh okay okay okay wait oh man I just
wasted my thing I keep pressing r2 by
accident okay here we go
oh there's another guy down there oh
there's two guys down there I gotta heal
myself I don't know how to [ __ ] do
this [ __ ] man
what I'm gonna get a [ __ ] laptop wait
what time is it
oh [ __ ] only got five more minutes wait
I don't get any progress for after but
just know oh man
I'm gonna lose all that I think oh you
know what we don't sneak up on this dude
oh [ __ ] just two of them right here god
damn I'm not gonna be able to do this
[ __ ] Oh ease drop I got our ichiro okay
why am i listening to these [ __ ] right
Fistful of ash I wonder if I should use
the fistful of ass oh I just used it on
myself oh my god dude you think I could
kill this guy right now oh [ __ ] and I'm
dead
you know what that's good I think I
accomplished a lot today you know what
do you guys think yeah I think that was
[Music]
so far because this [ __ ] yeah I'm not
I'm not mad at at that experience right
there I thought that was pretty good
let me see what I'm looking in the chat
thank you everybody that's been just
watching me today
you know what I mean and that was
Griffin Griffin coming and I thank you
guys for watching so I should have old
so if I would have went to the shrine
could I have saved myself from fighting
that guy again I probably could have huh
I'm trying to look at the chat and see
what you say oh could I have done that
could I resurrect it and then gone
damn dude that I don't understand oh man
is that guy dead oh [ __ ] these [ __ ]
things are after me
oh well well we did it guys I that's
like training so I'll be able to beat
that guy again and I'll come on and play
again I'm gonna play this game like you
know a few more times but that was fun
yeah I actually like this game a lot as
hard as [ __ ] but it's challenging but
you at least feel like you can
accomplish it you know some games
they're so hard with the shooting
mechanics or whatever the fight
mechanics that you can't even like I
have no chance but this with the LB RB
and the B it makes me feel like I
actually could get this done so next
time I will practice with the elite
controller so I could get to be dodge
with one of those other ones without
having to you know take my finger off
but we'll see I really appreciate you
guys watching Griffin gaming and please
watch our rhythm with Griffin you know
subscribe to my podcast if you're not
even watching that I go to my youtube
channel go to Eric Griffin calm
I got all the information on there damn
I said she make a make a thing for that
yeah so make sure you go check out Erik
Griffin calm I really appreciate it and
what listen and watch my podcast you
know I have some great guests on I've
had a good time doing it and big news
with we're friend with Griffin is I got
a sponsor I got a sponsor finally so
that's actually pretty exciting news for
my podcast can you believe that [ __ ] so
make sure you go to Eric Griffin dot-com
you don't I mean Eric over that guy
wears it there it is Erica fan calm if
you want to hear my podcast you can
listen to it on Spotify and all that
kind of [ __ ] but I really appreciate you
guys watching
I'm gonna keep doing this until I master
this game and don't think I haven't
forgot about call of duty I'm coming
after that [ __ ] too I got to get my solo
in and call a duty I've already won an
apex a Pyxis equator but I'm gonna win
and call the dude I want to get a solo
victory in that [ __ ] but I'm gonna keep
playing this game to sukira part to odd
preferred